what i want to do in this video is to
talk a little bit about
spectrophotometry
spectrophotometry
photometry which sounds fairly
sophisticated but it's really based on a
fairly simple principle so if i have
let's say we have two solutions that
contain some type of solute so that is
solution one and then this is solution
two and let's just assume that our
beakers have the same width now let's
say solution let me put it right here
number one
and number two now let's say that
solution one has less of the solute in
it so let me
let me make so that's the water line
right there so this guy has less of it
let's say it's yellow or to our eyes it
looks yellow so this has less of it
so this has actually let me do it this
way
let me shade it in like this so it has
less of it
and let's say solution number two has
more of the solute so it's more
so
i'll just kind of represent that as more
closely packed lines so the
concentration of the solute is higher
here so let me write higher
concentration
higher concentration
concentration
and let's say and this is a lower
lower concentration
now let's think about what will happen
if we shine some light through each of
these beakers and let's just assume that
we are
shining at a wavelength of light that is
specific to the uh that is specifically
sensitive to the solute that we have
dissolved in here but i'll just leave
that pretty general right now so let's
say i have some light here
of some intensity so let's just call
that
let's call that the incident
intensity i'll just say that it's i zero
so it's some intensity what's going to
happen as the light exits the other side
of this beaker right here well some of
it is going to be absorbed by our little
molecules inside the beaker so you're
going to have less light come out to the
other side i'll call this i 1.
now in this situation if we shined
the same amount of light into this
beaker so it's the same number that and
that is the same the same intensity of
light what's going to happen well more
is going to be absorbed as the light
travels through the speaker it's just
going to bump into more molecules
because it's a higher concentration here
so the light that comes out when you
have a higher concentration i'll call
that the intensity i'll call that i2
this is going to have a lower intensity
of light that's being transmitted than
this one over here in this case
i2 is going to have a lower intensity is
going to be less than i1 if you have
another beaker
that is maybe twice as wide
it's twice as wide and let's say it has
the same concentration as number two
we'll call this one number three has the
same concentration as number two so i'll
try to look at make it look fairly
similar and you were to shine some light
in here let's say you shine the same
light in here and you have some light
that makes it through that exits and
this is actually what your eyes would
see
so this is
i3 right there what do you think is
going to happen well it's the same
concentration but this light has to
travel a further distance to that
concentration so once again it's going
to bump into more molecules and less and
and more of it will be absorbed and so
less light will be transmitted so i2 is
less than i1 and i3
i3 is actually going to be the least and
if you are looking at these this has the
least light this has a little bit more
light being transmitted this has the
most light being transmitted so if you
were to look at this if you placed your
eyeball right here this one right here
would have the lightest color you're
getting the most light into your eye
this would be a slightly darker color
and this would be the darkest color that
makes complete sense if you dissolve
something if you dissolve a little bit
of something in water it'll still be
pretty transparent if you dissolve a lot
of something in water it'll be more
opaque and if the cup that you're
dissolving in or the beaker that you're
in gets even longer it'll get even more
opaque so hopefully that gives you the
intuition
behind spectrophotometry and so that the
next question is well what is it even
good for why would i even care well you
could actually use this information you
could see how much light is transmitted
versus how much you put in to actually
figure out the concentration of a
solution that's why we're even talking
about it in a chemistry context so
before we do that and i'll show you an
example of that in the next video let me
just define some
really some terms of ways of measuring
how concentrated this is or ways of
measuring how much light is transmitted
versus how much was put in
so the first thing i will define is
transmittance
and so when the people who defined it
said well you know what we care about is
how much is transmitted versus how much
went in so let's just define
transmittance as that ratio so in this
case example the transmittance of number
one would be the amount that got through
over the amount that you put in over
here the transmittance over here the
transmittance would be the amount that
you got out over the amount that you put
in and as we see this will this one
right here will be a lower number i2 is
lower than i1 so this will have a lower
transmittance than number one so let's
call this transmittance two this is
transmittance one and transmittance
three is the light that comes out that
gets through
over the light that goes in and this is
the smallest number followed by that
followed by that so this will have the
least transmittance it's the most opaque
followed by that followed by that now
another definition which is really kind
of a a derivative of the trans and not
in the calculus sense it's just derived
from transmittance and we'll see it has
pretty neat properties is the notion of
absorbance and so here we're trying to
measure how good is it at absorbing this
is measuring how good are you at
transmitting a higher number says you're
transmitting a lot but absorbance is how
good you're absorbing so it's kind of
the opposite if you're good at
transmitting that means you're bad at
absorbing you don't have a lot to absorb
if you're good at absorbing that means
you're not transmitting much so
absorbance
absorbance
right here and absorbance is defined as
the negative
log of transmittance and this logarithm
is base 10
or you could view that if the
transmittance we've already defined as
the negative
the negative log of the light that trans
is transmitted
over the light that is input but the
easiest way is the negative log of the
transmittance so if transmittance is a
large number absorbance is a small
number which makes sense now it's also
cool about this is there's something
called the beer lambert law which you
could verify and this is uh this is
we'll actually use this in the next
video beer
lambert law lamb i actually don't know
the history of where it came from and
i'm sure it's based on somebody named
beer but i always imagine it's based on
someone transmitting light through beer
the beer lambert
the beer lambert law and this tells us
this tells us that the absorbance is
proportional to the path length so this
is this would be how far does the light
have to go through the solution so it's
proportional to the path length
times the concentration
times the concentration usually we use
molarity for the concentration or
another way to say it is that the
absorbance is equal to some constant
it's usually a lowercase epsilon like
that some constant and this is dependent
on the solution or the solute in
question what we actually have in here
and the temperature and the pressure and
all of that
what's equal to some constant times
the length it has to travel
times the concentration let me make it
clear right here this thing right here
this thing right here is concentration
concentration the reason why this is
super useful as you can imagine so let's
say we have an axis right here
that's axis and over here i'm measuring
concentration
this is our concentration axis and we're
measuring it as molarity and let's say
the molarity starts at zero it goes you
know i don't know point one
point two
point three so on and so forth and over
here you are measuring absorbance in the
vertical axis you measure absorbance now
let's say you have some some solution
and you know the concentration you know
it is a 0.1 molar concentration so let
me write down m for molar
and you measure its absorbance and you
just get some number here so you measure
its absorbance and you get its
absorbance so this is a low
concentration didn't absorb that much
you get it i know some number here so
let's say it's point
point two
point two five and then let's say that
you then take another known
concentration at say 0.2 0.2 molar and
you say that oh look it has an
absorbance
right here
at 0.5 and i should put a 0 in front of
these 0.5 and 0.25 what this tells you
this is a linear relationship any for
any concentration the absorbance is
going to be on a line and if you you
want a little review of algebra epsilon
times the length will be the slope but
the the important thing to realize is
that you have a line here
you have a line here and why and the
reason that's useful is you could use a
little bit of algebra to figure out the
equation of the line or you could just
look at it graphically and say okay i
had two known concentrations and i was
able to figure out the absorbance you
can then go the other way around you
could then
measure for some unknown concentration
you could figure out its absorbance so
let's say there's some unknown
concentration and you figure out its
absorbance is right over here let's say
it's 0.4 then you can just go on this
line right here and you say okay well
then that must be that must be a
concentration of this well whatever
number this is and you could you could
measure it or you could actually figure
it out algebraically and so this will be
pretty close to 0.2 molar a little bit
less than 0.2 molar and we're going to
actually do an example of that in the
next video